the issue of abortion has divided the
united states in recent months in june
the supreme court overturned to reverse
his way that was the ruling that
legalized abortion nationwide in 1973.
june's decision triggered several states
and lower courts to re-examine decisions
and laws that restricted access to
terminations
the kansas referendum was not about
banning or restricting abortion but
about whether the state's constitution
should explicitly state that kansans had
a right to an abortion if the republican
move had passed and removed this then
their next move was likely to try to
either ban or restrict abortion
provision
kansas is a conservative state which
donald trump won easily in the 2020
election the referendum was the first
test of voter sentiment on abortion
rights since that supreme court decision
it was a resounding result and a cause
for celebration for pro-choice advocates
59 of voters chose to protect abortion
rights in a largely conservative u.s
state with ties to the anti-abortion
movement for some the relief was
palpable i'm super proud to be from
kansas tonight and i feel like my state
just showed up and boldly told me that
they are going to take care of me and my
female friends and everyone that can get
pregnant in the state of kansas we are
protected tonight others saw the kansas
poll as an indicator that plans to
restrict access to abortion are out of
step with the public mood
if abortion rights are uh are are
protected here in kansas and again
republican leaning state
i think that that indicates that there
is a big the the states that have those
trigger laws probably are out of step
with what their electorate wants
abortion opponents who supported the
proposed amendment said they felt an
obligation to protect the rights of the
unborn
but when we pull back and look at the
scientific evidence of what happens in
that womb
not the emotion and not
the fact that i'm i feel like i'm losing
something
the people that are losing life have no
voice if people on the on
like me don't speak for them
the strongly held views on both sides
were reflected in a sometimes bitter
campaign
but the decisive vote to keep abortion
protections in the state constitution
indicates a clear determination from
kansas citizens to protect women's
rights
well the white house issued a statement
shortly after those preliminary results
were announced it reads in part this
vote makes clear what we know the
majority of americans agree that women
should have access to abortion and
should have the right to make their own
health care decisions
we can get more from dw's uh stefan
simons in washington welcome stefan so
this un unexpected win for abortion
rights in a republican stronghold
yeah that's unexpected times two times
ten if you like uh kansas is a
ruby red state can't get any more red
more conservative than kansas they say
um and uh here's what happened you we
just heard in the report people uh major
turnout by the way 900 000 people went
to the went to the polls and that is
more than uh two years four years back
from now
before
so the turnout had something to do with
it and that is also a clear indication
for that kansans uh didn't want any
alter to alteration to their
constitution and wanted to remain in
their constitution the right for an
abortion right so what does this tell us
about the effects of july supreme court
ruling
well it's actually another indicator an
indication for what we already know
through the polls that 60 to 70 percent
of the americans they really dislike the
supreme court's decision
they didn't want roe v
wade overturned and now they have it now
it is at the states and now as you can
see as republicans and conservative
politicians as well anti-abortion
activists will
scale up their efforts to all the states
in the united states to go on with the
banning abortion or further restricting
abortion there will be a counter wave
now at least that's what the democrats
expect right and what what have the uh
anti-abortion campaign been saying about
this particular uh result
as you say it sounds like this is far
from over
yeah they're shaking it off so to speak
they're of course saying that this is
not the result they had hoped for but
that they will um try again and again
and again this is what this
anti-abortion
segment of of the population in the u.s
and the politicians who work with them
do they chisel away over years and years
and years decades actually until they
soften up the ground so to speak and
make then changes so the kansans
conservative legislator will probably
not rest and let this just be
and are there more of these votes coming
up across the states in the wake of that
supreme court decision
yes this will be rolling through the
states through kind of all the states
there a few democratic states already
said this is not going to happen there
won't be any referendum and they are
democratically controlled by democrats
of course but you can
assure i can assure you the deep south
of the united states as well as other
west midwest states will have that
same procedure maybe not a a vote a
constitutional vote but conservative
politicians trying to change the law and
push this through their legislature okay
looking ahead to november's mid-term
elections president biden gave a
prediction we'll take a listen and come
back to you
the voters of kansas sent a powerful
signal
that this fall the american people will
vote to preserve and protect the right
and refuse to let them be ripped away by
politicians
and my administration has their back
stefan simons does the president have a
point is this likely to be an issue
it's going to be an issue 100 guaranteed
it has to be an issue and here's why
because the democrats are actually
hoping that it will
working on that it becomes an issue
because this is how they can rally their
clientele this is how they can rally the
troops against
trump against conservative conser
politicians against republicans and the
vehicle to do this best as they figure
out right now and or have figured out
before actually and now if they feel
that they are
that this is confirmed they will try um
to frame abortion rights are under
attack your you and your freedom and
your liberty are under attack women's
bodies women
per se are under attack with those with
the conservative agenda you need to come
to the
to the polls uh midterm elections and
vote democratic so they'll use this
politic politically that's for sure all
right thank you for that stefan stephen
simon's in washington
well amy littlefield's a boston-based
journalist for the nation and she
focuses on reproductive rights she told
me more and she gave me her reaction to
this surprise result
i mean it's an absolutely astounding
victory i think many of the people the
abortion rights activists that i was
following during my reporting trip to
kansas were optimistic cautiously
optimistic that they might win but
everyone thought it would be close and
this is just a landsat landslide it's an
unequivocal message um to democrats and
republicans alike about the popularity
of abortion rights despite what the
kansas state legislature and the supreme
court
might want to do and and um so this is
hugely hugely significant i think
especially coming this close to to the
midterms i think it's really clear that
a sleeping giant of the the pro-choice
majority in this country has been
awakened um by the overturn of roe v
wade i talked to a lot of people who
were interrupted i'm interested in
why you think it it went this way there
was a quite there was an unusually large
turnout now do you do you think that
this was a vote that crossed um uh right
left lines do you think there were
republicans voting for this or was that
just
yes
i know there were republicans voting for
this because i talked to republican
women who are voting for this i mean i
think first of all this election had
been scheduled during a primary when
turnout was expected to be low and
heavily republican and clearly an
enormous number of people turned out i
mean turn out as high as 50 potentially
um you know the population of kansas is
only 3 million and they're estimating
more than 900 000 people turned out i
talked to republicans i talked to one
woman who was a friend of the
assassinated abortion provider dr george
tiller she was voting in tiller's former
church it was a precinct place and and
she said i'm a died in the wool
republican but i am voting no she told
me this very quietly um i know there are
republicans republican women out there
who voted no and kansas also has a huge
percentage of unaffiliated voters um 30
about of the electorate is is not
affiliated with either political parties
so i think it'll take some time but i
think
an enormous amount of credit goes to the
grassroots organizers on the ground in
kansas who were knocking doors phone
banking people who'd never volunteered
or participated before
who came out to participate in this
campaign in this historic time
they got the vote out um and
despite the way that this vote has gone
kansas is still not the world's most uh
liberal state just just give us an idea
about the state of the the of kansas's
abortion rights as they stand presently
i mean abortion is heavily restricted in
kansas you know it's it's banned after
22 weeks there's a
30 minute
waiting period that has to be done
between when a doctor conducts an
ultrasound and when the the process can
go ahead when i was in the clinic dr
taylor's former clinic which which
remains open um
in in wichita kansas um
the the counseling room has all these
ministry certificates on the wall
because the counselors either have to be
licensed social workers or they have to
be trained ministers and so they've all
gotten ministry certifications to do
abortion counseling so i mean it's
actually heavily restricted and they're
dealing with an enormous influx of
patients from texas oklahoma and
surrounding states um where abortion is
no longer an option for those patients
okay thank you for outlining that so
clearly for us uh journalist at amy
littlefield in boston thank you